i have a message to the radical
socialist democrats in the media mob
and big tech be careful for what you
have all
worked towards and wish for over the
last four years what do i mean about
this i've been thinking about this a lot
now all of you democratic socialists
democratic party with the aid of your
willing accomplices all things
democratic socialist an extension of
your press office the media mob
and your big tech cohorts uh may have
successful you may have been able to
hide
yeah joe biden during this campaign
which i would argue is a massive scandal
in its own right
and you certainly never asked the weak
frail cognitively struggling former vice
president any tough questions
never asked for example about his praise
of a former klansmen or working with
that former klansman to stop the
integration of schools
didn't want his own kids going to
schools that were racial jungles
you never asked that not once he never
gave a real answer from my
satisfaction on court packing but i'll
say this
good luck if your dreams come true and
your friend joe
is going to be haydn hayden biden in the
white house
here's a hannity prediction your dreams
come true
you better buckle up because i predict
what will be the i'll use the term
greatest political shift
show on earth will unfold before your
eyes and to be honest
with biden we all know that this script
is going to write itself you know it too
every democrat i know admits they cringe
every time he opens his mouth oh and
guess what
you own all of this you covered biden
you covered four biden
you never vetted biden you even let him
hide away
half the year in his basement bunker
you're fine with that
good luck trying to defend this
predictable mess the next four years
good luck defending programs
that well socialism has failed
everywhere it's been tried that will
fail spectacularly
and by the way i do promise you i will
be reminding people every single day
of how you fail to do your jobs fail the
american people
if your dream comes true biden will
become your nightmare
but unfortunately it will be the
countries also
and i'm going to add i honestly hope i'm
wrong
i hope i'm wrong for the sake of this
great republic
and i hope by the way for the people of
this great republic they're the people
that truly make america great
cnn msdnc cbs abc
nbc new york times washington post all
you big
tech giants that went all in anti-trump
for four years pro-biden
well pro haydn biden if i'm right the
american people will never
trust anyone not that they do much now
in the media mob or big tech or the
democratic party ever
again because you will be exposed as
institutionally
corrupt abusively biased and never to be
trusted
and notice you know no republicans are
having hissy fits on tv
none of them saying we're gonna move
we're gonna leave or this is a white
lash and all the craziness we heard
in the past no people aren't acting that
way they're saying count every legal
vote
uh and you've kind of proved it to us
anyway over the last five years you will
have broken it
and you will now own it but first let's
count all
legal votes like joe said he wanted